[Music]
welcome back to the Julian podcast Mumma
Dinks this episode is brought to you by
thread up right now you can get up to
90% off estimated retail on some of the
best brands out there okay isn't awesome
[Music]
clothing service and you go to thread up
that's thre DUP comm slash Jenna Julian
and you can get an extra 30% off with
that URL our names give you an extra 30%
off it's magic pretty crazy right also
guys the farmers dog is a great service
that we use to feed our dogs they just
love it every single meal time they go
completely apeshit for the farmers day
if your dog's a picky eater
whatever eating habits they they have
farmers dog or if they have no teeth
like our dogs farmers dog is there to
help you go to the farmers dog calm
slash annejulien get 50% off your first
two weeks and you get free shipping
check it out awesome service do it to
him for the dog host Kermit you had a
big day and now it's time to lay in your
bed sir he wants to cuddle
Corino cuddling any bed let's count how
many times you say no before he okay
yeah exactly it's not in his vocabulary
cuz it's just us I mean we're just
trying to figure this out here that's
just a scenarios hey hey look at us who
thought not me not me and I said I found
that we the last time we did like a QA
or an advice podcast was a quite a while
ago yeah and it's something that people
always request I don't know why though
like why do you want any advice from me
out and what the hell is going on I I
enjoy these ones but I do actually I
mean I feel like I kind of get a little
bit why people want advice not that
we're like qualified or anything but may
blow
but like I listen to podcast been
listening to a lot more podcast recently
it was like one of the things I've been
trying to do more and there's a lot of
podcasts that are purely that yeah it's
like answering questions and then that's
the podcast and they go from there or
whatever and it's not that we're experts
or anything but people just they want to
hear our take on things which I
appreciate yeah and I mean we do our
fair amount of silly things on this
podcast so I imagine it's kind of nice
every once in a while to just not have a
silly yeah no for sure I I agree with
that he busted out the cry well done
well done Kermit you did it to him my
guy so ok peach peach you need to get
your bed right now we really need a
better system for this every single time
we broadcast we just need disciplining
them all right so I asked on Twitter and
on Instagram peach in your bed in your
bed go in your bed right now
just leave her she doesn't scream than
me this one does
she was your money she doesn't money lot
I know she doesn't debt yeah so I'll
start with the Twitter ones and then the
Instagram I know the Instagram ones are
actually anonymous so I don't know if I
should read the names there none of them
are like any you know many questions
that people would want to remain
anonymous so I'll just read the names
but to start it off corn paw 1502 says
what is one thing that you loved and one
thing that you hated about college wears
a thing is a good question because there
was a lots of love and a lot to hate
about college I think one thing that I
loved about college was the location
that I went to college in and I know
I've talked a lot about this because a
lot of you guys I feel like are in that
stage of life so that's what inevitably
ends up being a lot of these questions
like during that portion of your life I
really I grew up in Rochester New York
which was you know for lack of a better
word [ __ ] boring no I mean it's great
there like in downtown but you know
growing up there it gets a little low
boring and I just wanted to live in a
city that was larger than Rochester and
so I was sort of going back and forth
between Cleveland
Baltimore Maryland and Boston mm-hmm and
decided yeah yeah and I applied to
schools in Baltimore and in Boston and I
visited Cleveland and I did really like
it there but I ultimately decided that
Boston was it just made me feel so happy
mm-hm and it never stopped making me
happy like even to the day that I left
Boston and moved that place never made
me not happy mm-hmm and that to me was a
decision that I consciously made for me
to do something I wanted which is live
in a city yeah and so that remained
probably one of the highlights for me
was you know being 19 years old and
living in an apartment just living in a
city and taking public transportation to
my classes there was no campus oh yeah
what I hoped would make me happy and it
really really did because it made me
feel like a person that was going to
school not like in a bubble of school
which i think is super cool and I'm so
fascinated by like campuses and people
like my friends that have gone to
schools that have campuses yeah what
their experience is like versus mine but
I just I thought that that was something
it was gonna make me really happy and it
really was and for me my least favorite
thing I guess probably is going to
school campus like our facilities oh my
god when I hear people talk about what
they had in college I'm like what the
hell man yeah there's some [ __ ]
amenities our gym was like a closet oh
yeah we didn't have a locker room like
our athletic director like building them
for all of sports was just on the second
floor of like a building that had like
regular classes on the third floor and
regular classes on the fourth floor and
the second floor was just like here's
the ADEs office yeah our softball coach
the baseball coach the worst gym you've
ever seen like literally twice the size
of this room but you know there's like
three treadmills and like a bench and
like a squat rack there like for an
entire 40 man baseball team 25 persons
softball basketball team that's insane -
ready yeah no d3o d3 yeah everybody yeah
and then a basketball gym in the
basement Wow where they can actually
shoot hoops yeah with him okay yeah
soccer team we had men's and women's
soccer as well nice that was we just had
that and I was like and they couldn't
practice like how much of the year what
do you mean like the soccer teams right
because it was it would be snowing like
we would drive 45 minutes to go to an
Indian damn that's crazy well if I went
to a school that would like how to
campus you know we probably have a place
to practice dude well so I had friends
who went to a massive universities I
went to a smaller school too
I mean we had amenities we had a campus
it was like it was nice but I had you
know I had a couple friends who you know
play baseball big school so I like for
instance like UCLA I got to Train and
all their facilities one you know a
handful of times absolutely
and I was like blew my mind of course
tons of tons of tons of money gets
brought into the school because of those
sports so I get it right they have to
you know put the money back into where
the money is coming from but it was just
it was like looking around like dude
these students they're the same they're
the same as me they're the same age
they're like in college but they have
this like huge campus with these insane
and I think I would have really liked
that but at the same time I don't know
it wasn't it wasn't for me it didn't
make sense for me and it didn't make her
break my expense so I felt like when I
was in school when I started the library
was like this dungeon yeah it was a
dungeon it was so old there's no windows
and like it goes down you know it like
you walk in on the first floor and it's
just like a basement of like Oh terrible
I hated it never wanted to go there but
then by the end of me graduating like
they were beginning to build a new one
yeah they had like the most beautiful
library but like I still went to dungeon
library and no you had on occasion out
like my I think halfway through my
junior year and my senior year I got to
go to new library yeah this is beautiful
and amazing I think for a lot of people
that's sort of like they have nice
facilities and I don't want to go
a dungeon school yeah but to me it was
more about the experience and I'm
wanting to living in a big city and not
have a campus for sure I didn't you know
you you just have some there's
trade-offs yeah I was trade-offs yeah
but it was it was great yeah I mean I
think I have a similar sort of answer
like my favorite thing about University
I would say or one of my favorite things
is learning independence and I'm like
getting to fully just dive into this
world of being an independent person I
think a lot of what I ended up doing in
college both like with my classes and my
jobs and just the [ __ ] I did on my free
time it was it was kind of shaped early
on in that like freshman sophomore
period where you're like I can do
whatever I want no one's responsible for
me but me right and that's it's a scary
feeling but at the same time it's very
empowering and for me I kind of loved
that and it kind of made me want to
thrive because it was like it's all on
me now I got to do something and
especially because I stopped playing
baseball I really had to figure out
where I was going and so I missed that
feeling and I'm happy that I I went
through that like that was a big
experience for me as like a person so
learning my independence and getting to
like run with it was great I hated my
freshman you've been roommates yeah I
did not like I mean not as people like
they're fine people you know there's
nothing wrong with but they were so
different for me both of them completely
different from each other but also just
very different from me and we were three
we had a three right there was a lot of
people I knew who got the good dorm and
I only had one roommate no no we had
three and I was in middle so I was just
basically like part of the furniture you
know and I spent a lot of time early
like first semester in that in that room
and I mmm it drove me nuts yeah throw me
nuts and it really made me well it gave
me a pre she asian for a having
roommates that I like you know in the
future of my college you know life and
then also just have
my own space now and how wonderful is
pretty good yeah so you know I think a
lot of people can relate to the the
first sort of people that you meet in
college you're hoping or you're gonna be
friends with but don't ultimately yeah
it like takes a little while to find
your tribe yeah when I went to school it
was 17 and my 18th birthday was that
September and I just remember laying on
my like dorm my little twin dorm but
just crying and being like I wish I knew
anybody the one hey I know and you know
one of my roommates I you know I
shouldn't say I hated they were good
people
honestly but I'd the one of my roommates
I got closer with because he was around
more right so we kind of just like we're
stuck together more like played video
games together we would go to Wendy's
and get a [ __ ] frost he together like
you know yeah like [ __ ] like that but it
was just yeah I don't know it just it
was this combination of this expectation
or feeling like oh I'm gonna be best
friends my room and then also seeing
people who were your peers that were
best friends that roommates you're like
damn that sounds sick I'm jealous I
can't come over to your dorm and Chi Chi
come over and pour vodka through your
Brita make it better
God busy Belle Belle says what Netflix
shows are you currently watching I it's
not a Netflix show but I just finished
the last season of mr. robot which was
incredible mm-hmm you haven't finished
you know I'm a few episodes behind I've
been watching a lot of NASA's
unexplained files but I think that's on
whoo that's on whoo I don't think
Netflix is the question it's just like
what shows um I can't remember the last
thing that was like last series I
watched a documentary about Bikram yoga
on Netflix oh what's that called I
forget oh that sounds interesting yeah
it was great good yeah there's so many
good documentaries on Netflix they're
just popping up every day
yeah I'm not one to complain about it at
all yeah I love documentaries yeah don't
we all
I again not at Netflix I've been
watching The Outsiders on HBO that is a
fantastic show Stephen King thriller
scary amazing murder mystery like all
you could ask for
I've also been watching Avenue 5 which I
am undecided if I like there are moments
when I laugh really hard and then there
are moments I'm like hmm you know came
from the office
you know he's keeping me watching I love
him he's keeping me they're keeping me
in the seats
I watched the OMA I'm almost halfway
through with the actually I don't know
if I'm halfway throughout and a half
through the pharmacists on Netflix that
was a cool like doc 3 part 4 part I
don't know you know multi-part series
really cool story the Anthony Aaron
sorry Aaron Hernandez documentary blew
my mind like everyone else
that is so insane as a Pats fan someone
who literally cheered the guy on like
watch the games and shouted go Aaron and
as like dude I was just standing I go
Aaron Hernandez that's all I said all
day
no I mean it was a big deal it was him
and Gronk and it was like the two most
dynamite tight ends in the league
together it was crazy so watching that
[ __ ] [ __ ] me up great storytelling
they'll like really well done i watch
what the health recently and i'm
probably a million other documentaries
have seen on netflix they're just kind
of everywhere but yeah it's just
suggesting really hey how about you
watch this now i'm you're like okay
netflix yep give it to me please
how do you eat at family functions while
being vegan gluten-free is it hard or
it's hard but bad habeases so for the
most part my family's like pretty spread
out all over the place
mm-hmm and so if we're eating like if we
go up north to visit my brother and
sister-in-law there are two incredibly
open-minded people and they're always
down like my niece has a lactose
intolerance I think at this point and
some nut allergies and between Julia not
be able eat we and we're vegan there
we're all just always like everyone's
very calm let's just figure something
out you know like let's everybody's very
respectful if it's a holiday at like
it's Christmas or Thanksgiving or
something like that usually Julian and I
will be like we'll bring our own food
because if it's on a day or a time when
like somebody has to cook for a lot of
people or everybody like will usually
just bring something for ourselves so
that at least that person doesn't have
to worry about figuring out our diet
yeah but like your mom always hezmana is
always been the best like literally when
Julian got diagnosed with celiac it was
like all right well if Julian is not
gonna eat wheat then I'm gonna cook with
no wheat so nobody eats wheat my mom my
mom when I got diagnosed with celiac
like 12 almost 13 [ __ ] years ago
holy crap she turned the entire kitchen
into a gluten-free zone there was no
more flour there was no more anything
that would get me sick on accident which
made my siblings [ __ ] pissed because
they were like what the hell why we got
to eat this crap because thirteen years
ago there wasn't that great gluten-free
substitute the pasta tasted like
cardboard the bread was non-existent and
then not only that she would go to
grocery stores and literally give them
hell until they finally offered gluten
free products so st. but to sort of
answer that question it's like we've
we've gotten to the point now after a
few years of trial and error where yeah
we just kind of bring the food that we
know we actually want to eat like our
favorite dishes of Thanksgiving or
whatever we'll make our own yeah and
we'll just volunteer that we're gonna do
it and say hey whatever you want to make
we're gonna do our own version of so no
bread no for other people if they want
to try usually people do want to try it
but um yeah if it's something we don't
want to like burden our family members
with cooking extra special stuff for us
because they're gonna be making a
non-vegan a large portion of Nod meter
I'm like I don't want to make someone
else do that one yeah yeah but in terms
of like family functions I mean I don't
have a ton of family here and you
usually it's like if somebody goes out
to dinner or something for a birthday
and your family have a lot of siblings
it's like I don't know your family's
just pretty conscious of Julian has
celiac and a lot of people have
different dietary needs so we'll just go
somewhere that has flexible options and
everybody can order something or you
know I imagine if you're in a family
that had like a lot of you know every
Sunday you go over and
eat together yeah that's another thing
we don't know yeah that would be nice
yeah if we did something like that we
have supportive family members so I feel
like we have a we're lucky to have an
easier time with but shout out to all my
friends out there who have dietary
restrictions shouts out your family
doesn't people [ __ ] about we care about
you and if they think you're annoying
who [ __ ] cares cuz you're not
annoying yeah that's what we offer to
either bring our own food or I mean
there's been plenty of times when we've
been in functions and things when we
just had to sit there and drink some
water sometimes you got to drink some
water yeah how many weddings have we
been to it where there's just like
nothing Oh weddings for me here's how I
treat a wedding seriously this is what I
think of when I go when I wedding in my
brain I'm like okay nice meal while
we're getting ready at the hotel yeah
off your face stuff my face before in
drink my heart away the whole time and
then get some fast food on the way home
I'm Lea that's what we've been doing
when we just yeah we don't eat it it's
kind of a good system we don't eat away
there's been a couple though that where
we had vegan food at weddings which was
incredible yeah which is always a bonus
cuz we're never ready for it we're never
like expecting it because it always says
vegetarian option which I'm assuming is
usually just like some pasta yeah but
there's been a couple times yeah when we
could eat at weddings that's true what's
a great time hell yeah
yeah the trick is eat before pretend you
don't see the whole time yeah I pretend
you don't eat I know you know it's like
an art when the food gets served and you
know here's you ordered this and then
it's a big deal everyone's like looking
at everyone's dish it's a it's an art
actually to play it off like it's not a
big deal like oh yeah thanks you know
you you like pick up your fork you like
move the food around just so you don't
look like you're standing out like it's
hard
Samantha rainy says what's the best way
to segue into the sponsors actually that
would be a great question to segue into
the sponsor thank you I appreciate that
that was really helpful is that real
that is real do you want to see a
picture of it Samantha
doing it to us Samantha have you checked
out threat up it's the world's largest
online thrift store with up to 90% off
estimated retail price that means all
your favorite brands that you're sick
and tired of seeing those big old price
tags on and you don't want to drop the
money but you love the brands for like a
man I like nice things well thread up is
here for you okay you get the great
deals associated with thrifting with the
convenience of online shopping what a
great idea
did they pitch this to Shark Tank or
something like that's a great idea
you can score some Nike for $6 or theory
for $20 maybe 21 I don't know it depends
on the day but all the brands that you
already like is there on thredUP and you
just check it out you can browse their
site
everything is high-quality in great
condition many still have the tags on
them if you want to update your wardrobe
it seems like a really great way to do
it without leaving the comfort of your
couch or your bed or your shower if you
have a waterproof laptop whatever your
deal is when you online shop do it with
threat up right now go to thread up
that's thre DUP comm slash Jenna
Julianne make sure there's no a-ok its
thread thre D they spell it their own
way you get an extra 30 percent off your
order when you use that URL
use our name for extra money off that's
what we're here for
Thank You thread up also guys farmers
dawg you know what your dog is unique
and special so should their food be
right mm-hmm
thank you their food sometimes just
looks like
I mean bunny eats kibble she's killing
she gets [ __ ] excited over that so
that's fine but these guys are spoiled
rotten and then we finally even farmers
dog and they were happy well marvel said
no teeth marbles had no teeth Jenny used
to have to sit next to him while he
chomped chomping with his gums and
honestly for a long time he gave up on
eating really I mean we had to really
sit with him and work on him and then
the farmer's dog happened in man
he changed it excited me his tail wags
he runs maybe like 50 I mean I know
greyhounds run 45 miles an hour but
marbles he runs 50 I mean on the scale
of how fast he's moving to like it just
looks like 50 miles an hour and he's
fuelled with farmers dog farmers dog
provides human grade recipes developed
by a board-certified vet veterinary
nutritionist so you know your dog is
getting the right foods and they'll let
you know they're getting the right foods
because they're gonna be happy they're
gonna be healthy and it's great they
formulate a specific meal plan just to
your dog whatever their eating habits
size breed they take all that into
consideration when they build their meal
plan and then they send it to you in a
convenient box and you just feed them
it's the easiest thing ever so go to the
farmer's dog calm slash Jenna Julianne
you get up to sorry you get 50% off your
first two weeks and free shipping when
you use our URL so check it out start
feeding your dogs they will thank you if
they speak English if they don't then
they're just gonna bark but I think they
mean thank you thank you sponsors
Scoobies Brooks says what is your
favorite treat yo'self thing to buy
treat yo'self thing to buy good question
honestly in the like the grand scheme of
treat yo'self I really like that drunk
elephant skin care is so lovely and I
know that skin care is like so personal
it could be anything for me it's that
and it's a that vitamin C serum is so
nice they're face wash I mean everything
they make is yeah and it's [ __ ]
expensive but like that to me is like I
love to treat myself to like a nice skin
care thing that makes me feel really
happy yeah it doesn't have to be that
expensive yeah when you just be a skin
care brat and then sometimes I'll just
fall asleep and don't use any of it you
know yeah no it is nice I think for a
long time mine was kidding Aggie mm-hmm
everybody just segi her like a rash
guard and I love you jujitsu an awful
lot I do yeah
and it was um I wouldn't buy them a lot
but it was like a treat yo'self thing
you know every once in a while now I'm
spoiled because I work with scramble and
they hooked me up with keys and so I
don't buy keys from from them anymore
but that was one thing I really did like
save up for and you know because they're
expensive they're not cheap yeah it's an
investment it is and then you got roll
in it you gotta break it in gotta break
it in then you got a hit with fabric
softener fabric softener
now I just buy like camera gear gadgets
I don't know but that's you know small
things I guess what was your first date
ok so there's like multiple answers to
this because we've I think ok
my first date no our first power our
first date I think that's what I mean
what was your first date Bridget was
your first date like it maybe they mean
in general I feel like we've talked
about us enough let's talk about our old
first dates see out no I feel you
haven't really been on that many like
traditional dates yeah I forget how he's
always like take your girl my swirl and
then I just be like hey oh mine was that
I Jenna the dance and the PE clothes it
was my first date that count as a date
oh yeah dude all right then
mine's prom our first date as boyfriend
and girlfriend was at swingers in Santa
Monica oh there was a little cafe so
everything yeah yeah we got pancakes Oh
a buckwheat pancakes [ __ ] wheat pancake
it was so good swingers my dude it was a
day date it was a day date how to live
without gluten on a college budget so
rice yeah so I would say I've actually
been watching a lot of bodybuilding
videos because they're just interesting
to me and there's a lot of goodbye does
keep pushing them to everyone I feel it
dude there's so much contact I sorry I'm
trying to make an entire like fitness
genre of like something like something
is happening because I'm getting
pushed non-stop fitness and like diet
videos maybe YouTube's just feeling like
y'all get fit [ __ ]
where they're like branching out like a
whole new branch you know anyway and one
of the wouldn't you know one of the
staples of gaining or bulking on a
budget right is like getting cheap carbs
right like could the rice the potatoes
things like that and that applies for
gluten-free because potatoes rice sweet
potatoes all those things are
gluten-free can be prepared gluten-free
very easily
gluten free oats just I would say go to
the store that you have near you to shop
and look in the bulk section where you
can buy like you take the scooper right
and you make your own bag of like oats
or rice that's a good way to save a lot
of money kind of money tournament you
can buy quinoa like that like anything
in the yeah and then you know this you
can get like whatever you like with your
rice whether it's like a soy sauce type
of thing or a stir fry thing or even if
it's just like playing with butter or
whatever you can get the bulk amount of
that stuff and even like frozen
vegetables are good too I think the rest
of your budget would depend what other
stuff you eat exactly what the rest of
your diet looks like me or and what your
lifestyles like yeah you need a lot of
energy really trying to save that money
you just eat some rice and beans my dude
yeah rice and beans or you know get the
industrial size thing of peanut butter
that's literally what I do so I would
buy one loaf of bread and like a big
thing of peanut butter and it just eat
it just like I used to buy a big thing
in granola and I would take it for
dessert I would tips on staying active
after your athletic career is over
oh don't ask me Madison
find a new athletic career that's my
answer that's Julian's answer it's been
hard for me as an adult to find
something that I care about other than
competitively playing the Elder Scrolls
online well to your to your defense I
mean you you work out a lot
you have a trainer and you take it
seriously you're just not doing a sport
am i doing a sport but if I had a choice
and if it was good for you I would do
nothing I love doing nothing so I don't
know how healthy this advice is for this
specific question but you can do nothing
I mean I don't I'm not gonna stop you
I feel like walking is one of the best
exercises you can do in general so
walking his differ the biggest tip I
would say is just like focus on
something really tangible and simple
like getting some more steps in and then
once you get there you can turn it into
five push-ups so you can turn it into 10
push-ups
you sure turn it into going to the gym
you know they can be small steps adding
up into bigger stems and you know keep
your mind open you never know what type
of like adult hobby presents itself that
you might only dude serious ideas that
gimen bad mitten backgammon that is not
a board game Parcheesi
okay monopoly jinx wait there's
questions for you
why are you I'm a Virgo who recently got
it I'm a Virgo I got it Aries boyfriend
what are some good tips on supporting my
tour you know okay
can't help you there noodle shark
hopefully your Aries don't look at you
like that hopefully your aries is like
really fun and really funny because that
makes all of their areas tendencies just
like incredibly tolerable honestly if
you were like a jerk like it would be so
difficult you know what I'm saying yeah
[ __ ] yeah but I feel like Aries have
these like childlike qualities sometimes
that just make them so charming and so
endearing and so lovely exactly he's
just waiting it I don't know like you're
impulsive and you do a lot of things
just as fast as you can and it goes
against a lot of what I feel but there's
a lot that you can learn if you're open
to in Aries and as long as they're not
being like complete
jerk but I imagine if he's your
boyfriend now he's probably pretty
awesome so hopefully very fun and also
understand that you might have some
differences but the more you can try and
understand them instead of like change
them or force them to do things your way
the better because I have things to
learn from you and you have things to
learn from me
you can pick your battles you can say
these are the things that we need to do
differently like make plans and
schedules sometimes and then in the days
when you just want to be completely out
of control you go have you out of
control this you know absolutely there
is a huge learning curve on the Aries
side of this equation so put your
boyfriend online your boyfriend on the
line I want to talk to him don't be
afraid to learn how to plan things okay
it's not the end of the world it feels
like it is but it's not the end of the
world I've learned a lot from being with
the Virgo so it's a mutually it's it's a
mutual process where you both grow and
learn if you guys can figure it out
though you can be very compatible in
that you the fact that you're opposites
oh yeah oh yeah my dude Mikayla says
tips on getting my first tattoo I would
say you're the expert do you know
definitely researched the place you're
going research places you know read
reviews make sure you're going a good
spot eat beforehand bring snacks and
bring headphones that's that's all I got
you know I said from deciding on more
you usually like find an artist that you
really like first right yeah yeah like I
didn't really go ham with tattoos until
I found Donna
which was the artist I was like I want
her I want her work so yeah be patient
you know if there's a way period it's
permanent so if it means waiting six
months you could if it's the right just
tattoo for you you're still going to
want it in six months you know my
Greyhound is incredibly lazy I don't
know how to wake him up to go for a
while
Eirene I've been walking bunny pretty
much every day and what's gotten her
excited is uh well literally she's
associated her collar I mean obviously a
lot of dogs and owners to this but she's
associated her collar and her leash with
walk time so I don't go near her collar
and a leash which is up on the shelf in
the mudroom
I'll go near that unless we're going for
a walk cuz I know she knows that if I
touch that and more than 60 seconds pass
she's gonna start barking because she's
like I'll give you a minute to put me in
the car to take me to the park but if
that passes I'm barking because you
don't touch that leash and so I think
like just getting a healthy Association
and also just man routine like they
thrive on a routine if you can do it
four days a week it's better than one
day a week or you know as many days a
week II you can squeeze even a short
walk in let's get him on a team there
Greyhound sees the leash and still just
lays there because they're incredibly
lazy I would say use high-reward
something that they absolutely reward
you know even better than a treat that
you would give them to train or like
everyday look some human food that they
absolutely go crazy for get them up and
then be like I gotcha look where we
going yeah outside for a walk yeah and
that's true eventually you can hopefully
cuz that's how we got bunny to get
excited to go to bed and she still has
nights where she'll be like I'm not
quite sure if I want to go up the stairs
yet it's on the the scare the stairs
aren't the problem she would just rather
sleep on the couch like a giant baby
yeah they love to just be babies no
problem with the stairs she doesn't mind
being in our bedroom she just wants to
watch Seinfeld on the couch and she
wants to sleep on the couch she wants to
sleep in the game room like she wants to
sleep where she wants to sleep which is
her spots you know so what I've had to
do is completely trick her and bring a
high-value reward and get her all
excited and get her up the stairs and
shut the door and say I got you I got
you baby
no you can't go downstairs and watch
Seinfeld yeah someone commented on the
stream the other night they were like
you should you should get Gerry's it's
completely ridiculous
you should get Jerry Seinfeld to come
heis bunny come to the house the
surprise but like imagine a dog being
surprised by a celebrity who's in a TV
show that they liked a lot but he just
she would ever recognize any face the
funniest concept um
when but when peach was a little wee
baby she didn't know how to walk she
knew how to she knew the act of walking
but she didn't know how to go for a walk
we had a teacher what do you mean we had
so we had to bring treats I had to bring
treats and I would take it was really
cute she didn't know how to like the
concept of walking around the block was
like why would I do this so we had to
like take her out front and I would give
her a treat I'm gonna walk like
literally two steps and I would say come
and get this treat and she would walk
and get it and I literally did that for
the first like I don't know how many
over walks we did yeah until she got it
and she was like oh this is what we're
doing
so that might be a route you could take
as well also - we bought the little you
know how if you ever seen a dog trainer
that has like a little specific pouch
that looks like a fanny pack but it
opens on the like a yeah a hinge that
specifically made for dog treats so you
can super close it really quickly and
give your dog treats I would say as a
last resort maybe to get if your dog
really won't walk and they don't want to
walk
we bought it on Etsy and I'm sure you
can find them other places but we puts
that put some treats and that thing and
be like let's go they're literally like
this it's really helpful we're gonna I'm
gonna give you a tree every 30 steps and
then you Whittle it down to every 50
steps every business for money you get
one treat away yeah we did have to use
those to desensitize her to everything
when she was afraid of yeah good luck
with the gray Esme Vargas says at home
workouts broke uni student who's
intimidated by athletes at school gym
exercise is free yeah guess what there's
not that either of us are qualified to
give you like a home workout but there's
so many people on the internet that are
like you can just google stuff YouTube
is your best friend there's a
a lot of really helpful do some research
make sure you're finding good stuff it's
a lot of really helpful bodyweight mmm
you know training circuits that you can
do in a small confined space they're
made for like hotel workouts like things
like that as far as equipment goes the
only thing I might recommend is like a
set of resistance bands because those
are really great for doing full-body
stuff too it's just kind of totally it
adds a little bit more than just doing
like full-body stuff with nothing mm-hmm
yeah because you can really hit your
like every muscle group that you would
want to hit with a basic workout at the
gym in the confines of a small dorm with
just a resistance band or not yeah and I
mean if you if you get to a point where
you need something more you could get
like a kettle bell or like a jump rope
you know depending on your space if
you're on a in an apartment and you're
on the second floor you know maybe you
don't want to be jump rope in 20-14 bar
slamming maybe you do
how should I prepare for the transition
out of my parents house are their phases
good question I mean I think it's
different for everybody I think it's in
for everyone and I also think it's
different now than it was when when I
went out of my parents house and when
Jenna went out of repair and it's
different for different cultures totally
people that live in different parts of
the world yeah I mean I would I would
think like my advice is I'll try to keep
it as general as I can but like if you
have a situation where your parents or
you know parent are the resistant the
idea of you leaving they don't want you
to leave they'd rather you stay and help
them I would say you know look at that
as an opportunity to step outside your
comfort zone explain that to your family
and you know make a selfish decision you
know cuz I think even though it might be
against what some people you know have
you know this idea about in their brain
like oh no you gotta stay and help save
up money whatever I mean maybe that is
right but I would say that if you do
feel like you don't strong yeah if you
feel strongly that you want to get out
there and be independent live on your
lawn live on your own I would say you
know stand by that and believe in it
even if you might not be the most
popular
decision in the household currently and
and then also on the other side of
things if you're if you feel like you're
being flowing out of the house at you
know a high rate of speed and you're
like I don't know what the [ __ ] to do
I'm scared like that's normal right yeah
that's normal
well I think the phases that you're
talking about or maybe like feeling kind
of homesick for a while and then 100
percent ago you I think it's sort of
like maybe not like a staircase kind of
like a weird escalator you know it's
sort of like not a really bumpy ride but
like maybe a weird one so like there's a
little homesickness and it's really bad
but then it's like you're doing okay and
all you find some spots that you like
these are like you know your grocery
store and if your world is kind of small
to begin with and like I like that
coffee shop or like I like to go to that
park and walk around like you start
getting familiar with your surroundings
and like making a little world for
yourself and then all of a sudden you
really homesick and something happened
and now I'm scared and I wish my mommy
was here but then oh my god I'm chilling
like I think it's it's not stairs and
it's not like a linear thing yeah a
little bit but I do think that it
improves over time and that it does get
easier and it becomes like we're really
great at adapting people in general
humans yeah so if you give yourself time
to adapt you can adapt absolutely
because I know a lot of people for them
once they move out within that first
month two months six months they're like
I have to go back I have to I hate it
here and I think for some people that's
true and that's fair and that's all
right decision for them but for other
people it might just be like this is
that part of the roller coaster where
you can stick it out if you would like
to you don't have to but that it you can
it can get easier totally not for
everybody I mean it's a case-by-case
basis but yeah uncle Jon says what's
something you had to learn the hard way
no um you shouldn't do backflips off of
docks yeah you shouldn't stand on your
knees leaning up on the front of a
speedboat either oh my god Julian what
that's so scary and I'm like going fast
you don't control the speed if you're a
passenger speed what speed you because
all speeds can be slow slow is still a
speed we get pulled over on the water by
the lake top do you know how fast you're
going I'm driving the speedboat I'm okay
also don't bring vinegar or dressing in
your sandwich bag that you put in your
locker in middle school because it might
spill and the smell up the whole row of
lockers
totally what do I do if my cat won't
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up every morning
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
it's good how do you train your dogs
this is a good one for you I guess I
don't know you're good training them
you're gonna teaching them things thank
you I mean they love attention they're
very the littles are all the same in
that if your marbles incarnate mostly it
depends on your dog but like fine what
their currency is mm-hmm for Kermit and
marbles both like they love treats don't
get me wrong but the like the good boy
like the excitement is their currency
all day well Dermot will do anything for
a good boy to just feel like the
attention is on him and that he is so
great he will do anything that I want
peach pure food bunny I think we're
learning her currency but for the most
part right now is still treats she'll do
most stuff for treats like she won't do
the hard stuff
for a good bunny yeah you know yeah but
for some dogs it's a toy and for some
dogs it's a pet for some dogs it's
where's the bat for me what's their love
language
it's
great advice learn their currency yeah
and use that I think you can teach them
how to exchange their currency you know
so like spirit crier you exchange at the
airport
no like Spitfire like you have to teach
a dog how to do dock diving right why is
the dog interested in grabbing that lure
maybe your dog is driven by food but you
have to teach them that in order to get
the food they have to go do that and
then do it yeah but I think you can
teach them that this thing means good
and reward and praise or food or
whatever you can change their currency
button hmm you have to figure out what
they want first yeah you know it's a
great way to communicate with them and
also just something I've learned and I'm
still learning is have a lot of patience
with them because you'll make headway
and then you'll stop making headway
you're like what the hell is going on
that's totally fine it's totally fine
it's normal you know you just got to
work with them this last question is for
you how do I get my boyfriend to stop
BJJ choking me Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
choking me shout out to your boyfriend
Porsha Silverwood I feel like anytime
I'm in any position that is sort of like
jiu-jitsu Julian like grab me and then
he'll be like protect your neck and I'm
like it's not my fault you're not
protecting your neck I told you a lot of
times you got to predict the man my
advice is Carrie rosewater nothing
dangerous carry it in your hand
24 hours a day he comes for your neck
you take it you unlock the cap you put
it in your mouth you spit it back into
his head you spray rosewater in his face
and you say begone perp okay what about
remember we were filming myself all
video and you like picked me up and she
said I'm calling the police I mean
that's very bad advice but but so is you
know it's a funny question
I don't know if you figure it out let me
you know basically I'm tired of
protecting my neck tackling that is does
work that works
me I can't I can't continue of you know
the attacking if I'm being tickled or
defend yourself I'm pretty strong I kind
of wrecked you sometimes but I'm not
good at the mechanics of you are how the
[ __ ] strong I am especially in my
upper body yet actually destroyed him on
an upside-down person yeah but technique
always wins I'm not talking about
winning I'm talking about surviving [ __ ]
I survived just long enough to tickle
you and escape to him be gone purpose
you sick your Kermit on me yeah he's a
good boy oh I don't want him sect on me
he nasty well thank you guys for sending
in your questions I hope you enjoyed
that's a good time that's us giving you
advice even though you know we may may
not be qualified but are you here for
expert conversations no okay I came here
if you are go to the go to the next
podcast or in the next room
[Laughter]
yeah go over there anyway thank you guys
again for submitting the questions I
hope they were of some sort of use to
you I don't know maybe not I enjoy
talking about my own you know life
experiences in relation to yours I think
that's a that's a fun thing because a
lot of you guys are going through things
that I went through you know and you
were like how do I do this I'm like well
I don't know but I did this when I did
it you know I don't know but I did this
I don't know I don't know
but I hope you guys have a wonderful
week we'll see you guys next week on the
podcast and on the stream have a good
one be good and we'll see you later
[Music]